[Music]
what is up everybody and welcome back to
the season seven finals I am your host
Justin Kruger community developer on
Rainbow six siege and we are about to
reveal operation Parabellum year 3
season 2 operation that takes place in
Italy
this crowd is hyped to hear all the
information that is coming in season 2
and to help me break this down please
keep that excitement going for my
amazing panelists Jeremy down Doucette
level designer on Rainbow six siege and
Alexander Carr pauses presentation
director on rainbow succeed please give
a big round of applause Jeremy how's it
going man I'm doing pretty good buddy
how you doing great you enjoying
yourself at the finals I'm loving it
it's tense and you're this is the first
time on a panel as well as Alex it's
your first time too Alex how are you I'm
loving it it's amazing yesterday today
the matches are incredible matches are
incredible this crowd has been
incredible we love you guys yeah we love
you so much and thank you to everybody
tuning in on Twitch YouTube's mixer
across the board on all the all the
streaming channels for operation
Parabellum we're really excited to get
into operation Parabellum of course
coming with operation Parabellum we have
two new defending operators and a new
map villa and let's start off with that
new map villa jeremy let's break it down
how would you describe villa for the
people villa is the kind of place you'd
want to go on vacation if you're in
Italy it's a beautiful massive villa
vine yards beautiful vistas it's lovely
it's picturesque it's exactly what you
would think a villa in the countryside
of Italy would look exactly it's just
really pretty it is you know is the art
team did a really great job but as per
usual with anything that's rainbow
there's a darker side to it the family
has been forging and selling art and
alibi was there and
cover a long time ago and rainbows
coming in to put a stop to it as always
there's a beautiful side this this map
looks gorgeous but there is chaos and
destruction and a lot of things going on
on this map how does it play the map
plays really well balanced the wind I
went through in slide design this map it
was made to go ranked and to go pro
straight away so there was a lot of
focus on navigation and flow and
viability of the bombsites and it is one
of the most competitive maps you you've
built it this way you worked on this
from the ground up yes where did you
start when designing this bat I slide
with a pen and paper in 2d I just go and
look at the silhouette of the building
and how it's gonna look
overall in just the world and then I go
through and start knocking out where I
want to put corridors rooms you know and
the flow from outside to inside I go
through and I start looking mocking up
bit by bit just on paper and then I
rough in the bomb sites think about it
do a few iterations and I go straight
through and I just start building it and
then we start playing it straight away
right so you start off with old-school
pen and paper that's that's really
old-school Jerry yeah I'm an old man
you've been designing levels in this
industry for a very long time and it you
really always start off with that pen
and paper that's something that you you
design and from that you iterate you
build it in 3d you create different
designs from it out of that and then you
create this flow and you test this flow
and you make it competitive in a way
that that feels good as a game as an
experience it's it's iteration and
learning as you go you really need to
just look at it look at the angles look
where the doors are look where the
windows are and look at the rotations
that can possibly happen from the design
and that's one of the great things about
being a level designer is you can just
go through and if it doesn't work you
can just erase it and start again and
you know there's been a lot of different
versions of this map the very early on
when we started play test with the pros
the pros liked it they loved it they
were like okay this is gonna be a good
map there was one bomb site that wasn't
really that viable but I just went
through memory we reworked it and
actually just made it just that much
better you know couple of days worth of
work and then all four bomb sites are
viable and it just going keep going you
know if it doesn't work start again so
through these play tests you you tweak
it you work it you rework it maybe
change a few things and they felt as
though this was very competitive we've
been talking about how it's a
competitive map what makes it so
competitive I believe the reason why
it's so competitive is because of the
viability one of the bomb sites and the
rotation possibilities on the bomb sites
and then when you add in the destruction
of this map and how many walls are
destructible its you can open up a bomb
site you can open up and having you to
attack you can shut down avenues as
defense it's it takes a long time but we
went through and we just got it perfect
and you know it's going ranked so it's
great yeah it's going in ranked of
course and it is being considered for
the pro and upcoming pro league as well
which is really exciting so let's break
down some of the strategy that is going
to be seen or potentially seen on this
new map and let's start with the
tactical view of the attackers and where
they're they are going to spawn so let's
take a quick look at that so here is the
outside you have three main entrances
the main entrance the fountain and the
ruins or three spawns you have three
spawns main entrance you can go through
and dismount a little bit different
there's actually safe-ish
entrances to the basement so he fish
issues nothing is safe in rainbow right
so from the main entrance you can go
through cellar into the basement from
ruins you can go through the side and
then go through to the Crypt entrance
and the same from the fountain so you've
got three really great spawn points and
three really great avenues just to get
to the building it's and when you see it
it's easy to call out and it's really
nice and parts of really good and quite
quite well balanced so you've been
talking a lot about the inside building
so let's take a look inside the building
let's go inside and break down the
defenders
points with their bomb sites as well and
let's start off with the first floor and
let's take a look at the two bomb sites
on the first floor on the first floor we
do have kitchen dining and lounge
library let's start off with that first
bomb side kitchen dining room what's the
best strategy that we're gonna species
on that Jeremie kitchen dining was
really interesting because just at the
back of the kitchen there's a set of
stairs that go down through the pantry
into the basement so you've got a really
fast rotate that allows you to go
through basement back up and out and
there's hatches as well what's different
with this map is we actually don't have
any exterior access to any bomb site so
you always have to go through a room you
have to commit to the bomb site you
can't just jump through a window plant
and run away yeah and as we're gonna be
seeing in this bird's eye overview
you're you are gonna see a lot of
buffelgrass is what's that it design
intention behind buffers the reason for
the buffer rooms is because we want the
team to commit to the plant we don't
want them just to jump in and then go
far back and like hold their plant from
a long distance we want them to have to
stick around and actually try and defend
it and that's the reason why we did it
just to make it way more viable and more
competitive and you know whenever
earlier talks about this map there was
actually one of those entry points and
became just way too easy to access the
bomb site but you guys changed that I
know we've we flaut changed it kitchen
dining is a little bit too easy to gain
to the bomb site from the fountain so we
changed it added a few different parts
and a few more destructible wards and
just locked it down to make it way more
viable and then Ashley Young was at that
time but that's the beauty that's the
beauty the pros come in and actually
have their feedback and even you know
high rent players come in and play cool
so let's stay on the first floor here
and take a look at the second bomb site
which is lounge library tell us a little
bit about lounge library Jeremy that's
what I be super interesting as you see
in that info in the lounge there's this
little nook that you think that's the
best like best place to go and hide a
little nook and cranny no no no but just
behind the if you don't reinforce the
walls behind that look then you're just
completely open for like someone
shooting through the wall
you have to remember that between the
first floor and second floor it's
completely line of sight everything's
destructible apart from the top of the
stairs so it's really easy to defend an
attack a bomb sight from above if you
really want to end that that
line-of-sight floor is really gonna
become crucial crucial for defending
these or even attacking these because
you can put pressure on the defenders
from that site as we've seen a lot on a
map like border that does have one of
those line-of-sight floors we saw that a
lot this weekend where people are
pushing through that or even defending
through that as well it's one it's one
of the great things to see the
strategies that come out when the maps
are actually released and the same thing
when this comes out on the test over on
Tuesday I'm gonna be really interested
I'll be watching how people play it and
that line-of-sight flow is gonna be key
especially if you're attacking these
bomb sites absolutely key so that is a
look at the first floor let's take a
look at the second floor and the two
bomb sites that we have there are
aviator games and trophy room and statue
room Jeremy let's break down this first
bomb site here which is the Aviator room
and the games room the games room Navy
rooms really fun the bomb sites are
actually adjacent just for a breakable
wall but there's also a rotation path
through a vault where you see them you
see the hammer on the wall oh that's
that's where we see the sledges hammer
in the in the beautiful case that you
might have seen in the teasers or
something it's up on the wall do the art
guys love to just put stuff there's a
lot of Easter eggs I've noticed in this
map there is a number of Easter eggs
it'd be interesting to see how long it
takes the community to find them or
actually but what's really interesting
is the bomb sites are adjacent to each
other with a breakable wall and there's
really fast rotates and you're in close
proximity to red stairs and you're also
in close proximity to the main stairs
from the main entrance so the
opportunity for rotations and all of the
bomb science is brilliantly and that's
one of the main key aspects of this map
is the rotations that are gonna be
really crucial it brings in a lot of
strategy as well it's it's gonna be key
for teams is communication and how
they're gonna rotate on and off of the
science even when you're attacking how
you're gonna rotate and there's so many
viable options for rotations on this map
it's kind of
and as we're seeing here there's a lot
of destructibility - yeah this with this
with the newer auto shotgun you can just
take walls out it's like you can just
open up the flank pass and just destroy
Italy gets destroyed on a daily basis
when we're playing in it it's really
always interesting and again when I
start building the map I start with all
of the walls being destroyable and then
I start taking them out to balance the
sights and to balance the flow that's
really interesting and now you mentioned
rotation and let's take a look at the
second bomb sight on the second on the
second floor which is trophy and statute
there's a really key part of this bomb
sight that I'll allow you to talk about
yeah this one's really this one's really
interesting it's actually my favorite
bomb sight it's because the bombs are
across an alcove across the red the red
corridor so basically you can fight
across the alcove which is really
interesting you're super close to the
Astronomy room which allows you to get
downstairs to the main red corridor
again but you can always just fall over
the over the railing straight into the
red corridor there's also a breakable
wall at the ends where you can break the
wall and try and control the red
corridor from above but it's it's a hard
thing it's a hard thing to achieve
yeah and we're taking a look at that
alcove right now or just a few moments
ago that becomes a really critical point
of chaos and tension and but it also is
allows for strategy with the rotation as
well even if you have a bomb site on the
first floor or maybe even especially if
you have a bomb site on that first floor
and you're defending or attacking from
that second floor that's a quick way
down to push the site it's it's super
fast it's quick for anyone to get
through and rotate obviously in the
bedroom there's a hatch you can blown as
well but there's also the other thing is
there's the skylight and if you're
feeling brave you can try and attack the
bomb site from the skylight we saw a
really good skylight played there in the
the last map that was there was it was a
non-resident yeah so that is the first
floor and the second floor broken down
let's take a look at the basement the
basement is really crucial for many
different reasons
especially because there's no bombs
there's no bombs iPad it comes into play
it really becomes a crucial point why is
it so important it's really important
because it's key for the rotations
because you've got the main stairs the
pantry stairs the red stairs and you've
got this is where you're gonna rotate
through all of the time that's also
where you're gonna enter from because if
you come through the [ __ ] tunnel or you
come through the cellar tunnel you're
coming through to those massive wine
barrels that you're seeing on screen now
and you're entering through through the
barrels and as soon as you blow that
you're giving away your position but you
can also just come through the garage
which you know you're not gonna make any
noise it's just a door there but what's
really fun is you see the hatch is in
the ceiling and you see and you see all
of the stairways and all the ways to go
so when you're when you're defending and
kitchen/dining you're gonna you're gonna
rotate through this when maybe if you're
up in statue trophy you you need a quick
rotate you might end up coming back
through and up around and it allows for
really good flanking paths so it's a
really viable way for the attackers to
push in meaning that the defenders may
have to have one Roemer down in the
basement or or even really just keep an
eye on that especially if they're on
that first floor and they don't want to
get pressured to too early from the
basement that's gonna be pretty pretty
key the maps pretty the map is Roma
friendly that's for sure gromer friendly
map but it's tense like it's you know I
know I know the map like the back of my
hand I've been doing building it for
eight nine months now and you know I'm
surprised by the different ways that I
get killed almost on a daily basis in
this map just different ways of getting
killed a lot of angles a lot of
destructibility that is a really amazing
map and I cannot wait for players to get
their hands on this map and you'll be
able to play villa for the very first
time on the tester servers starting May
22nd which is Tuesday yes you say it's
so short close yeah super excited fans
here are really excited and that defense
like
to be so much fun they're finally gonna
be able to play your baby villa it's
released into the wild now I get nervous
because I don't know you know the
rainbow community is great and it's very
polarizing they're either gonna love it
or hate always say it's like Marmite you
know your novel here and I'm hoping the
community really likes it because I had
a lot of fun the production team had a
lot of fun building their snow
hats off to the entire production team
in Montreal because I think we pulled
off a really great competitive map
awesome well that is a look at Villa but
that is not everything that is coming in
operation Parabellum of course we also
have our two new operators maestro and
alibi they are defense operators the
crowd here is hype to take a look at the
them for the very first time and of
course operation chimera may have
favored the attack side but operation
Parabellum will favor the defense let's
take a quick look at the ub blog video
breaking down these two operators the
new villa map coming to Rainbow six
siege in operation para bellum may look
like a nice spot to relax but attackers
will need to be on high alert
to deal with the devious gadgets that
the two new defending operators from the
Italian CTU are putting into play
[Music]
one of the most important skills and
siege is spotting your enemies before
they spot you but what if your enemy
wasn't your enemy say hello to alibi and
alibi and alibi and alibi only one of
them is your opponent
the rest are holographic decoys alibi
can throw her three decoys anywhere but
they'll only deploy if they have the
space they can't hurt you but if you
shoot them or touch them your position
will be compromised immediately and
you'll be marked repeatedly for the next
few seconds which is that watch out for
decoys pretending to spawn peak and
decoys pretending to hold angles watch
out for decoys that used to be decoys
but are now just alibi pretending to be
a decoy doing any damage to the base of
the decoy will destroy it and as long as
you don't shoot or touch the hologram
while doing it you won't be marked
twitch is an especially good decoy
hunter Thatcher can disrupt them for a
bit and glasses sight won't be fooled
you can also keep an eye out for visual
discrepancies the decoy always wears
alibis default clothing and wields her
storm SMG without any attachments
so if you see alibi wielding the new AC
s12 shotgun you'll know she's the real
deal
so what happens if alibi'd chucks a
decoy outside well like a defender who
runs outside the decoy gets marked but
marks are different when alibis in the
match because they don't reveal the
operator's identity so a decoy deployed
outside and a defender that runs outside
will look the same unless the attacker
can actually see them with their eyes
though the decoys mark expires after 10
seconds that's 10 seconds with a lot of
opportunity for mischief and mischief
just might be alibis most effective
weapon by making you doubt your own
eyesight and second-guessed your own
reflexes alibi gets in your head and
that's not where you want a defender to
be five seconds remaining now we all
know how powerful cameras are in siege
but the second new defender maestro is
equipped with cameras that are a new
kind of powerful behold the evil eye
it's bulletproof
it can see through smoke it shoots a
freaking laser beam maestro can plant
his evil eyes on floors or walls just
like Jager does with his abs and once
installed they're hard to get rid of
bullets or melee hits won't work you'll
need to use explosives or destroy the
surface it's planted on or call in your
old pal sledge for a quick demo jump
Thatcher and twitch can disable them
temporarily but as long as the shutter
is closed evil eyes are free to be used
as cameras by anyone on the defending
team they can mark targets and they can
see through smoke so you'd better be
sure there isn't one watching when you
rappel in through a courtyard roof
opening and try to plant the defuser but
the evil eye doesn't just spectate
when maestro is using one and aims down
sights the shutter will slide open to
expose a laser once the shutter is
completely open maestro can fire the
laser to destroy drones blow up breach
charges and damage attacking operators a
single shot may not do a lot of damage
but you can fire in rapid succession and
this can be very dangerous for an
attacker with low health deploy in a
good spot and you can quickly land a
bunch of shots before your enemy zeroes
in on you or you overheat the laser when
the shutter is open the evil eye is
vulnerable to gunfire and melee attacks
and remember that the laser won't
interrupt a defuser plan it's up to
maestro and his LMG or ACS 12 shotgun to
clear the room
if you see dastardly new gadget
strategies prepare for operation
Parabellum and to keep up with the
latest in rainbow 6 siege visit us at
news you be soft calm and subscribe to
the Ubisoft YouTube chat
[Music]
thank you to Chris waters for breaking
down those operators and giving us a
brief glimpse at the upcoming operation
Parabellum Alex I'd like to bring you in
now please allow us to break down these
operators a little bit further a little
bit more in detail because it yeah
because there's a lot to unpack in the
video and let's start off with alibi
who is alibi let's get get to know her
sure her personality is someone who's
very stoic and reserved her background
is she immigrated to Italy at a young
age then she grew up joined law
enforcement it succeeded there she
joined GIS and actually went undercover
in operations for them that's really
where she kind of learns her tricks of
the trade deception manipulation the
mind games and that translates right to
the game play yeah and speaking of her
game play she has a comes equipped with
an amazing gadget yes this is one of the
most unique gadgets I've ever seen in
rainbow succeeds this holographic image
of herself
how does she play yeah so she is a
trickster and she's a bit of a hybrid
character where she roams she places
they're called Prisma these she gets
three of these decoys to plant around
and then it's all about
counterintelligence pretending where you
are when you're not actually there or
misleading the enemy team into thinking
you're many places at once and as we saw
with maestro he is a true form of
intelligence gathering that's right
alibi kind of falls in this middle
ground where she's not technically a
trap operator but she's not technically
an Intel operator but she has these
counter counter and how ability yeah
there's a duality to that and also she
can receive Intel if you happen to shoot
her decoy or drone through the decoy or
even throw it outside and to pretend to
be your details
as we saw in that that I mean those are
really interesting strategies that we've
seen in your play test in while
designing this operator what did you
feel in you know what was the vision
behind it it was really about making the
team second-guess what you're doing at
any given time so we actually found that
her decoy is hugely successful with
beginner players and even expert players
yeah and so that's psychology let's
break that down a little bit further
because I think that's really important
that we discussed that psychology a
little bit from the day one yeah of
siege we are taught to aim for the head
shoot and and be have really lightning
fast reactions especially true on a pro
scene stage like this yep now we're
asking players to change that a little
bit or maybe not change it but
second-guess themselves and that's
what's great about her she introduces
this kind of hesitation or doubt and
that means that alibi can capitalize on
that capitalize on it and create
different strategies like we're seeing
here where it was you know you we have
that house house of mirrors strategy
which is just so so much fun where you
can deploy all three alibis and and kind
of just like mess around yep have fun
with that it's really a point for an
attacker to kind of pin down the right
alibi what do you think is the best
strategy you've seen with alibi the
house Amir's one is really great there's
also ways to synergize with her so you
plant a shield in front of her gadget to
protect the base maybe people have to
jump through to disable it and they fall
into a frost trap or there's kapkan trap
there's a lot of ways to synergize with
it just a while she may not be a true
trap operator she has a lot of synergies
with trap operators and she has a lot of
synergies with the whole team in general
because she does have that unique
passive when she deploys a gadget
outside of the
outside of the defenders boundaries
that's right actually the passive is
shared to the entire team so anybody who
runs outside of a map location won't be
immediately identified so you can
pretend to be alibi or actually throw
her gadget out there and it'll be an
unidentified operator yeah so really
making the defense have an opportunity
to be aggressive aggressive super
aggressive yeah yeah I mean we may see
plays where we haven't seen them before
may see strategies with the outs outside
and the out-of-bounds area is becoming
these more crucial areas that's what I'm
hoping for cool so that is a quick look
at alibi and as we saw see in these
video she comes equipped with a crazy
loadout yes please tell us a little bit
about her loadout because you know she
is a a roamer yeah at heart as well so
break down the loadout for us so her
signature weapon is a storm SMG so this
is a high rate of fire low damage but
fairly good accuracy which means she's
deadly in in most distances and as we're
seeing she's a three speed 1/1 armor
that's right so it helps her with
mobility it helps her set up before a
match place all of her gadgets and start
roaming and getting that intel on the
team and what about her second primary
she actually has that for the first time
in the game a shotgun pistol which is
hilarious and a lot of fun and it
actually synergizes well with her kit
you can make some peeking holes that you
can set the gadget behind and kind of
fool people into thinking she's peeking
yeah and one thing that we should note
here that there are speed changes coming
with operation Parabellum so with the
three speeds and the one speeds there's
a few things changing right so three
speeds are going to be a little bit
slower and one speeds are going to be a
little bit faster but if you do have a
secondary pistol equipped you will gain
a little bit of a speed boost which
means you could see an alibi with a
shotgun pistol run at your face it's
gonna be cool that that's really scary
I'm a little friend
including since she's gonna have like
three of herself around the map as well
so it's gonna be terrifying it's gonna
be a little bit terrifying but to
counter that tariff the terrifying
aspect of alibi who would you say our
best counter picks uh well she does use
a gadget so you'll see there's IQ who
can spot it out when you have twitch you
can destroy it easily with the twitch
drone and even a Thatcher EMP will
disable it temporarily one of the
hardest counters is glass of course
you'll be able to see through any of the
decoys and only the real alibi will
light up yeah so if you do have you know
a glass peeking somebody on defense
trying to rush out yeah you will have
glass as a advantage there too because
that's a really aggressive move it is I
you know you be hard to really pull that
off but also as we're seeing with
Thatcher it temporarily disables the
decoy so it's not a full hard counter
but a little bit of a soft counter to
know if she is doing that how some ever
years trick yeah clears the room and
there's the room what would you say is
the best way to counter her honestly if
you get a super aggressive alibi who's
kind of roaming and playing like a run
out glass is going to be able to shut
that that down immediately
shut shut her down obviously see see the
outline of the true alibi and not get
deceived right cool
so that is a look at alibi and now let's
take a look at the maestro I love him so
much
maestro is a very charismatic leader he
has a bit of history with alibi he
joined the GIS after that he went solo
and ran his own boot camp so he's a
natural leader a natural teacher and now
Witten he's with Rainbow six he's a
great operator to kind of hunker down
and protect the point and he just looks
cool men this guy has so much charm I'm
jealous I love as we saw also if you're
following on Twitter just melosh yep
cosplay Daz
as as maestro and nailed it yes nailed
it this was really awesome I wonder why
did see more cosplay of maestro out
there but let's get into his gameplay
how does he play yeah so his gadget is
the evil eye and he gets two of these so
these are turrets that he can place
around the around the map and you can
place them anywhere were just like
Jaeger you can put it on the floor you
can put it on the on the walls and then
you can use it as a camera if it can see
through smoke and it is bulletproof but
when you open up the visor you can
actually shoot some lasers shoot some
lasers and those lasers only deal about
five damage per shot it's low damage and
even though it's continuous you can
overheat it so you can't just hold down
and wait so there's a little bit of a
balanced err exactly and when you're
shooting the laser it means that your
six your you can actually be destroyed
by bullets right so so it's a little bit
of a high-risk high-reward there if you
are trying to stop that bomb plan or
trying to get just harass people yeah or
just shoot people in the butt like I do
with twitch that is a possibility yes it
is absolutely
so he he's sort of defined as a true
anchor where what makes him an anchor
well he gives a lot of intel on a plant
site so you want to be able to position
both your cameras on both plant sites or
at least destroy enough so you get that
vision and you can start giving that
Intel you to your team because he has a
few similarities to like an echo for
example he has that stopping power he
has that has that Intel
would you say he plays like an echo like
a smoker he's actually in that same
family of being able to stall so if you
see a plant going down essentially if an
attacker walks into a room and sees the
camera they're gonna have to take care
of it otherwise you know that maestro's
feeding information about what you're
doing feeding information potentially
even stopping
that plant I think I've even seen some
strategies where people will have to
maestro camera setup and they'll just
hop back and forth between can be so
annoying with that it's great so
annoying so he's even also can even even
fall into a harasser categories exactly
yeah in a similar way that twitch can
kind of do a variety of things maestro
is gonna be really crucial in various
aspects yeah he has a lot of utility
yeah especially if there is if they are
kind of pushing from the top side or
defending from the top side on Villa as
well they can have maestro set up in the
second floor or even in the basement
just keep an eye on things that's cool
maestro maestro actually plays really
well in the villa Lee plays really
bullying bark Maps actually like I
played I played at the middle for long
I've made with alibi an awful lot but
maestro yeah in micro plus villa it's
fun that's a fun time plus the Italians
are equipped with these these just
explosive power and and and brute force
yeah destroy this entire you know this
entire beautiful Villa but you've worked
so hard on that it's it's it's a real
shame but I don't design full operators
because you don't want anything to be Oh
peace so the first time I was actually
playing and I heard that auto shotgun I
was really wondering what it was I'm
like what is this and I was busy
building the map and this wall just
disappeared in front of me I'm like oh
okay this is oh that is my shirt yeah
this is real now yeah and speaking of
that auto shotgun let's take a look at
his loadout really quick here yeah after
we we take were cut back from this
gameplay but his loadout is pretty
interesting it is he has a lot of
utility and can be built different ways
he is a three armor one speed so he's
pretty beefy so he's a thick board he is
and a sick boy in Rainbow six we've
given him a lot of tools to to play
around with that so like you said he's
really about brute force when it comes
to his load out he has an LMG and
because he is a one speed you can put an
ACOG on that if you want
your reaction coming from the crowd here
wait to see it
anyways that's gonna be really
interesting especially he is you know
the one speeds are getting a little bit
of that speed boost so there's not as
handicapped as they were before right
with that ACOG we may see if you spawn
Peaks or it could be run out it could be
but then again you want to have your
maestro lie for as long as possible to
anchor down so right he doesn't have a
really great passive yeah because while
the cameras are useful yet they can be
useful the true utility of it comes with
the laser exacto he runs out and dies
then you're kind of defeating the
purpose of having maestro on the team
right yeah and as we see with with
picking band being introduced into the
pro league that's going to be way more
crucial in the future absolutely on the
flip side his other primary is that full
out of shotgun we've been seeing a lot
and it can delete walls and floors it's
pretty crazy and that also works really
well giving him a lot of line of sites
with his cameras milania sites with his
cameras just opening up walls being able
to create the environment that maestro
wants to live arrives in yeah exactly
he's the kind of guy that just like I
don't like this wall good vibes gone
yeah I could see that yeah let's go it's
just gone sorry Jeremy's just cries a
tear every time my stroke deletes the
wall this so much destruction in Italy
and soon as he turns off everything just
goes away but it's good fun and he also
has that revolver shotgun tutorials
great morals yep just two shotguns let's
go yeah so that's really awesome I'm
really excited to see maestro in action
but who would you say are his counter
picks again it is a gadget so you'll see
the same kind of counters as you will
with alibi you have IQ you can spot them
out you'll have twitch and that
who can disable it temporarily which is
incredibly useful but of course you want
to destroy it too so you do have sledge
that can just run up and smash it yeah
smash it which makes sense it doesn't
know it just it just logically it's like
he has a sledgehammer this is a camera
it's gonna be gone yeah I really love
that but also we you know we mentioned
echo we've mentioned smoke we mentioned
the pick and bans yeah do you feel as
though maestro is a good alternative to
those because if there is a pick and ban
in pick and ban you could potentially
see a map without a smoke or without an
echo and that means that my show could
be picked alongside that exactly he you
can either be a good alternative or
actually if those options aren't taken
off the table with the band system you
can synergize really well to create this
super stall composition yeah and there's
also one word that we haven't touched on
too which is dhoka dhoka be yes she can
pop into the camera she can't use the
laser but she can use his camera she can
use his camera which is a man that is
that is really exciting it is really
exciting
great so that is a look at maestro and
alibi and villa that is really exciting
yeah but there is way more coming with
operation para bellum because if you
want customization items we got
customization items we have to BD use
that are arriving with operation
Parabellum one for alibi and one for
maestro these are
head-to-toe customizations that do come
with the year pass so if you do have own
the year 3 season pass they you will get
these right off the bat day one so if
you want a fancy-looking alibi or a
fancy-looking maestro on day one you can
have that additionally
drum roll please we have a new elite to
show off that I don't think has been
leaked yet that elite is the Thatcher
elite that's that this elite pin comes
equipped with a MVP victory animation
winning screen comes equipped obviously
with a weapon skin a charm and a fattier
face reveal a good-looking face reveal
it's good-looking he's a good-looking
man nice he's like a rugged I'm gonna
mess [ __ ] up guy yeah that is uh that is
a really cool look at fetchers at least
and I can't wait for that I'm just like
I'm like this is awesome
you know we saw it so often in siege
that our operators are behind us Moke
mask or some other kind of mask and we
don't get to see their face they lovely
face and Thatcher looks pretty cool
great so we do have a ton a ton more
coming with Operation para bellum that
will be arriving on may 22nd on the test
servers you do not want to miss out on
some of this stuff that we're about to
cover as well let's break down some of
the new features that are coming in
let's start off with the new secondary
gadget the bulletproof camera yeah this
camera is obviously comes equipped on
six defensive operators and was in one
of our test servers before it kind of
looks a little bit like maestro's about
a camera but you can't move when you're
in it how does it help us does it differ
it can see through smoke like his camera
can but it can be destroyed in a number
of different ways it can be shot from
the side and it can be male aid as well
so there's a couple of different options
you can do to take it out a couple of
different options obviously it is a
gadget so those those gadget destroying
abilities counter it as well but a
really interesting a secondary gadget
that's coming to six operators so that
that will be really interesting to see
you know how that changes a few
different things alongside of that we
since we have a new secondary camera we
have a new primary camera with a unique
gadget we have to introduce a new
observation tool as well and echo also
is getting a second echo drone with
operation parabola yeah there are a lot
of cameras now so many cameras how did
we resolve that issue so we updated the
observation tool so that you can jump
between a lot of different gadgets and
the gadget families that they are
belonging to so this should make it
really easy to jump between all of your
team's different gadgets so this is me
on the surface look like a quality of
life change because you can cycle
through the gadgets you can have an
easier pathway of rotating through those
but it's really a fundamental introduc
it was absolutely necessary to do the
change to echo and to bring my store to
life bring Buster will bring echoes buff
to life exactly another change that you
may notice in operation Parabellum is
the counter defuser devices team G so
this is a new animation that we're
introducing why are we doing this
animations mainly because it's a little
bit silly that you're smacking a box end
it so this is just something that kind
of fits the world a lot better yeah this
was on the test server so it's gonna be
really nicely change coming in in
operation Parabellum also coming an
operation Parabellum we have the
discovery playlist the discovery
playlist is a special customized
playlist that allows you to play Villa
and only villa in casual for four weeks
at the start of the season
you will be able to play vanilla and
only Villa so you don't have to play did
you hear that guy you know he screamed
my crowd really loudly there that's a
really great to hear the enthusiasm for
this for this Manu change
Jeremy you got to be thrilled I just
play your map I'm absolutely thrilled
that people not just go in and play it
and rather than play ten rounds of house
and you know get through they can just
go through jump casual and just practice
just go practice and learn the map
there's a lot to learn so it's I'm
stoked that we have this playlist now
it's really cool
I can't wait because I know that that's
been one of the biggest feedback
whenever we do launch the season they're
like I got to play these these maps and
these maps and these maps just to play
one round of the new map and now you can
just jump right into it and that is
going to be available for four weeks at
the start of the season and will be
available on the test server as well so
keep an eye on out on for that the final
change
well not the final change we have a ton
of more changes that we can't cover in
this panel and patch notes will be on
online on Rainbow six comm on Tuesday
May 22nd but one of the final changes
that we're going to be discussing today
is one that we announced at the six
Invitational which is the map buff for
Clubhouse I know people really love this
Jeremy the significance of map puffs are
huge map knowledge in Rainbow six is
huge so what what is the reasoning
behind these changes basically to bring
up-to-date to make it more current to
make it more can
- well they really like this to make it
look better and to play better is why we
doing the map box it's it's this map you
see it was a great map already it's just
so much better now so much better and it
means that it's a going to be
interesting to see how the pros adapt
have every player adapts to that new
change coming with operation Parabellum
and it's becoming a key strategy moving
forward as we're going to have more
buffs in the future that were including
a something that is way bigger than a
buff which is a rework of the map yes
those reworks and buffs buffs are we go
through rearrange to furniture now you
know like someone's come around being
drunk and move to your table is pretty
much what a map buff is a rework is we
actually go through and we completely
rework the map from the ground up and
basically you see a new map a new map if
you want more information on all the
things that we talked about right now in
this panel head to Rainbow six comm and
check out some of the dev blogs that we
posted about all these changes and more
once again that is a look at operation
Parabellum please give a big round of
applause to Alex Jeremy the running us
through operation Parabellum will be
available on the test servers starting
May 22nd